this next comic is a banana moss instant
legend
please give it up for
hi i'm sarah colonna i'm not sure how
you guys are dealing with the quarantine
and the lockdown
for the most part i'm very rational i
realize we're doing what we need to do
but
every once in a while i snap and just
scream open it all
up whoever makes it makes it i need to
go bowling
i miss bowling and i don't even bowl
i do have some tips for you guys to
break up the monotony
of quarantine um on tuesdays
have taco tuesday that way you know
that it's tuesday on wednesday
eat the leftovers from taco tuesday and
that way you know
that yesterday was tuesday
every four days or so put on a pair of
jeans
make sure you still got your life
together you know and then take those
off and put your house pants back on
because you're not going anywhere
i do miss going places the other day i
had a few drinks at home and
had my husband drive me around the block
while i sat in the back seat and
pretended he was an uber
it was fun until he charged me
it's the little things i think i'll
never take for granted again
that i miss the most like happy hour you
know i just miss
going to happy hour with my friends at
five o'clock on a friday
instead of drinking alone in my living
room at nine o'clock in the morning
it's gotten a little bit out of hand
i'll admit the wine has been flowing i'm
a little nervous because my annual
physical
is due at the end of this month but i've
already
told my doctor i am not coming in unless
she agrees that this year we grade the
liver test
on a curve i think we all need that
i did learn something new actually
through all of this um
people do workouts for their face
they do face workouts i found it
scrolling
on instagram it was called like face gym
and it's just people
doing this i guess to like lift and tone
or whatever
and they show you how to work out your
face and i watched
a tutorial for 45 minutes
um just watched it by the way didn't do
it that's where i am
you know too tired to just go like this
apparently
but in my defense i did exert a little
bit of energy at one point because i
started panicking about covid and
screamed stop touching your face and
threw my phone across the room
thanks for having me drew
[Music]